bonjour et bienvenue pour cette science
aujourd'hui consacré aux noms espèces
inspiré par la mondiale serve saga star
wars
sacré génération y qu'il soit bacheliers
étudiants ou collégiens si vous leur
parlez de véritables merveilles de
l'univers en classe de la biodiversité
animale ou de comment la classification
rempl il s'en ficheront impérialement
par contre par les liens du nouveau star
wars de maître jedi de sabre laser ou
deux croiseurs interstellaire et là vous
déchaîner les passions
un raz-de-marée d'attention ou déferlera
dessus mais comment en tirer le meilleur
parti la classification biologique c'est
pourtant indispensable pour envisager la
biodiversité terrestre
mais voilà la taxonomie cambon
l'appellent ses ultras relou alors quand
on sait quelles ressemblances
troublantes unis parfois les personnages
de la saga star wars à notre ennuyeuse
réalité on se dit qu'on aurait tort de
se priver de cette opportunité
du coup voici pour les enseignants et
les plus curieux d'entre vous à
florilège d'espèces de l'eau non a été
aspirée par la saga star wars à petit
échantillon choisi de biodiversité pour
égayer vos cours de biologie et de
taxonomie et croyez-nous il ya de quoi
faire parce qu en taxonomie on a le
droit de tout faire y compris de donner
les noms pourvu aux espèces tant qu'on
les justifie correctement et pour
certains vous verrez que la
justification n'est pas piqué des jo on
commence par les mammifères pas de
primates et lasmea ruminants fossiles
aux curieuses air de girafes zeno keryx
hamid à l'oeil cette bête à cornes pour
le moins curieuse a été nommé en 2015
par une équipe espagnole en référence à
la reine amidala je cite parce que c'est
comme ressemble à l'une des coiffures de
la reine amidala dans la menace fantôme
véridique et pour continuer nous allons
maintenant partir à tataouine
vous êtes déjà allés chercher les
dinosaures à total oui parce que
figurez-vous qu'on en trouve mais si
tataouine à petit coin perdu de tunisie
tellement perdu qu il a servi au
tournage des scènes se déroulant sur la
non moins perdu planète tatooine tête
wind tataouine vous aurez compris que le
nom de la planète est le nom de ce lieu
ne se ressemblent pas que par pure
coïncidence
et c'est là qu'on a découvert un
dinosaure sauropode au look ou tataouine
et à en 2012 du côté des poissons
maintenant voici un petit poisson
sud-américain de la famille des poissons
challes laveur de carreaux paix cole
sear gleadow nommé en 2015 d'après le
chasseur de primes extra terrestres
greedo d'après l'auteur de cette espèce
cette dénomination ne serait pas
complètement étrangère à la ressemblance
de leurs beaux chants ventouses
il était un peu du regard aussi non mais
la saga star wars c'est surtout les
sabres laser et ceux qui les manipulent
le jeune homme et les jedi alors quel
genre d'espèces glorieuse at-on nommé
d'après 7g die je sais pas si elle est
très glorieuse mais voici un emmy cordes
et de la famille des entérocoques 9 yoda
purpura tu as découvert en 2012 ce nom
lui vient je cite encore deux célèbres
latéral qui ressemble aux oreilles de
yoda les licornes et comme you nature
pure attaques sont parmi les invertébrés
les plus proches des vertébrés
ils partagent tant les faits avec les
poissons d'eau ni même descendons la
présence de forts courants kial des
sortes de branchies mais même si fier ce
sont donc des animaux important qui nous
aide à comprendre l'origine de la grande
famille des vertébrés à laquelle nous
appartenons
car de ce point de vue là les ennemis
corps des fossiles comme et kraft lite
ne sont pas nasri grand secours et
puisqu'on parle d'un vertébrés fossiles
voici le trilobites qu'on a baptisé en
2004 du nom du tombeur de ces dames
yanis solo et la ressemblance n'est pas
flagrante
certes c'est parce que son nom lui a été
donné après qu'un chercheur et parier
qu'il donnerait un nom star wars jan
las de ces fossiles sans que personne ne
s'en rende compte ainsi dans la
publication il est écrit que le nom de
jean rihanna vient de l'ethnie
majoritaire en chine
les à nous puisque c'est dans ce pays
qui fut découvert et que solo vient du
fait qu'il était le dernier représentant
de sa famille particulière de trilobites
les diplômes newsted et restons dans les
arthropodes avec darth vader ou green
cela d un accueil un baptisé en 1996 du
nom de danse veille de dark vador en
anglais un acarien les caisses qui
s'exerce d une blague il avait pas plus
impressionnant pour le nom du plus grand
méchant de la saga
en fait pour se justifier l'auteur de ce
mot a déclaré que cela lui a semblé une
évidence quand il a vu l'aspect
effrayant de la bête pour la première
fois sous le microscope armandie avec
est ce que c'est que cette horreur
espère entrer des roms alors toujours
dissipe toujours parmi les terrifiants
arachnides voit l'avenir apte au stick
us sarlac une araignée nommé en 2012 par
bandes james nom jason bandes elles
partagent en effet avec le sarlacc du
film une technique de chasse bien
particulière cachée au fond d'un trou
retournons vers les jedi avec le petit
crustacé al bugno nude à un mise au pod
c'est-à-dire un membre de la famille des
cloportes découvert en 2003 et qui vit
en parasites dans les branchies de
crabes et des crevettes
il paraît que la tête de la femelle qui
est beaucoup plus grosse que le mâle
ressemble à celle de yoda mais bon on
arrive maintenant dans l'amphi entre
attaques des insectes et de la même
façon que pour les noms inspirés du
seigneur des anneaux
les entomologistes se sont fait gros
plaisir avec star wars
déjà les incontournables fourmi un amant
câble du monde des insectes parmi
lesquels en 2012 on a découvert les
tetra moyenne jedi cartel les chevaliers
jedi
elle se comporte le site comme une sage
et noble gardienne de la paix de la
fourmilière noter que plutôt que
d'appeler la version noir thé tram orium
site
ils ont préféré l'appeler tetra moriame
nazgul quand je vous disais à propos du
seigneur des anneaux
il nous avait déjà gratifiés de 5 nommés
vers des hobbits et pour star wars on a
le droit à un combo x 3 polémiste us
chewbacca polémiste is very et polémiste
us oyonnax et c'était en 1983 et qui de
mieux pour représenter les fragiles zèle
d'un délicats papillons que la finesse
et la subtilité raffinée d'un rookie en
2009 le puissant chewbacca elle s'est
retrouvée gratifié d'un gentil mignons
petits papillons de nuit parce que je
sais toujours cl son poilu voilà non
dans ses coûts chez les scarabées on
aime bien les casques alors forcément à
la vue de la rutilante cuticules noir de
celui là il n'a pas fallu longtemps aux
anthologiste pour lui trouver un
épithète brillant agati diom valérie
encore une fois et non le taf melzer
s'est imposé de lui-même
il est à noter qu'en plus du diabolique
dark vador les mêmes auteurs ont aussi
dédié en 2005 le nom d'autres
représentants de ces petits insectes
mangeurs de cadavre et d'excréments à
des politiciens américains tels que
george deubeuliou bush dick cheney ou
bien encore donald rumsfeld
y aurait-il un message la vérité est
ailleurs et pour terminer last but not
least certainement l'espèce la plus
impressionnante de cette liste c'est la
bactérie midi claudia mitochondries son
nom donné en 2006 il vient dé médicaux
rien de microscopiques symbiote dans le
sens des jedi qui leur confère un
contrôle inégalé de la force les medics
loria sont eux-mêmes largement inspiré
des mitochondries de la vie réelle des
mini cellule à l'intérieur de nos
cellules qui nous permettent de
transformer le sucre en énergie grâce à
l'oxygène
les mitochondries nous bien mettre ni
plus ni moins que de respirer elle c'est
pas comme contrôler la force mais ça me
semble quand même essentiel alors
maintenant prenez une tique
puis prenez un anneau vert de ses tics
puis prenez une cellule de cet ovaire de
sceptiques
à l'intérieur de cette cellule se
trouvent des mitochondries on est
d'accord
et bien maintenant imaginez qu'à
l'intérieur de cette mitochondries
vivent une bactérie encore plus de
petites le symbiote à l'intérieur du
symbiote de l'intérieur de la cellule et
bien cette bactérie deux fois en deça
biotique
vidic loria mitochondries la bactérie de
la mitochondrie de la cellule de
l'ovaire de l'attique du bout du pal du
bout de la queue du chat de la fille de
madame marthe à ses mythiques lauréats
en conclusion nous espérons que cette
liste non exhaustive ravira les petits
et les grands
d'un point de vue plus scientifique on
pourrait quand même se demander si c'est
bien sérieux tout ça
tous ces scientifiques qui donnent des
noms sexy à leur nouvelle espèce ring
pour faire parler d'eux pour sûr ça
sonne un peu marketing tout ça mais
honnêtement tu avais beaucoup entendu
parler d amy cordes et à vent qu'on en
appelle un yoda et tu le savais toi fais
mitochondries elle pouvait avoir un
autre symbiote à l'intérieur d'elle
peut-être que oui peut-être bien que non
mais ce qui est sûr c'est que tu t'en
rappellera beaucoup mieux maintenant tu
sais qui portent des noms que tu prenais
déjà grâce à star wars
les scientifiques se font de la pub et
ça ça rend les choses beaucoup plus
accessible pour nous alors si tout le
monde y gagne
il n'y a pas de raison que ça s'arrête
pour notre plus grand plaisir et puis en
matière de science fiction la fiction ne
se gêne pas pour puiser allégrement dans
la science alors pourquoi la science de
bretelles supprimer l'impôt des strass
et des paillettes d'hollywood
merci à tous et que la science soit avec
vous
ah oui et au fait tout ce qu'on vient de
vous dites est 100% vrai les noms
d'espèces et leurs justifications tout
absolument tout alors n'hésitez pas à
les consulter les liens qui sont dans la
destruction si vous souhaitez vérifier
ou juste rigoler un peu on les a tous
mis et plus encore